pas notre émission spéciale vous l'avez
compris évidemment elle continue on va
se projeter maintenant dans cette
semaine
décisive qui commence le gouvernement
peut-il trouver une majorité de députés
pour voter cette réforme première
réponse grâce à Jonathan Dupriez
l'étape du vote au Sénat terminé c'est
une semaine à haut risque qui s'ouvre
pour le gouvernement avec un premier
obstacle à surmonter mercredi la
commission mixte paritaire au cours de
cette réunion cette sénateur et cette
députée doivent s'accorder sur une
version commune du texte si un accord
aboutit c'est cette mouture de la
réforme des retraites qui sera présentée
jeudi au Sénat puis à l'Assemblée
nationale pour être votée par les
parlementaires le gouvernement table
ainsi sur un accord entre les deux
chambres pour éviter de passer en force
via l'article 49-3 de la Constitution
qui reviendrait à adopter la réforme des
retraites sans vote lorsque je suis en
train de vous dire c'est quoi c'est un
on veut pas utiliser le 49-3 à part on
vit on se réveille pas le matin en se
disant ah tiens on aimerait bien faire
le 49-3 et la deuxième chose c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on ne voit pas pourquoi
il faudra utiliser le 49.3 précisément
par Z confiant mais précisément parce
que les LR du Sénat ont voté le texte
mais problème du côté du Palais Bourbon
sur fond de désaccords politiques
internes une partie des députés LR des
centristes pourraient ne pas voter le
texte
reconnaissance ne dispose pas de la
majorité absolue pour adopter sa réforme
sans ses forces politiques d'appoint le
gouvernement il a maintenant des heures
difficiles devant lui parce que il doit
s'assurer de sa majorité
dans sa majorité relative on sait très
bien que un certain nombre de députés
légitimement comme ailleurs ont des
états d'âme parce que eux aussi ils
regardent par la fenêtre ou à leurs
électeurs qui défilent ils se demandent
si il est bien pertinent de voter le
texte c'est la vie la pression sera donc
maximale sur les députés hésitant que le
gouvernement essaie d'ores et déjà de
faire rentrer dans le rang quant au
syndicats ils sont toujours déterminés
et appel à une nouvelle journée d'action
ce mercredi de quoi marteler encore et
toujours qu'une majorité de Français
s'opposent à la réforme mais vous voyez
bien que le match il est pas fini je
crois que les parlementaires ont une
responsabilité ils ont quand on vous
êtes au Parlement vous représentez les
gens qui vous ont élus pour le faire et
que chacun et chacune des parlementaires
est en face d'un choix de responsabilité
des syndicats qui pourraient prolonger
la mobilisation même en cas d'adoption
de la réforme jeudi de quoi empêcher le
gouvernement de tourner la page d'une
séquence très imp
notre édition spéciale consacrée à cette
réforme des retraites votées adoptées
samedi soir au Sénat continue évidemment
avec Béatrice Giblin bonsoir bienvenue à
vous vous êtes directrice de la revue
Hérodote et vous m'avez apporté ces mon
cadeau du soir le dernier numéro du
premier trimestre de cette année
géopolitique des ressources naturelles
Bruno pallier bonsoir bienvenue à vous
directeur de recherche
Océane du CNRS au Centre des études
européennes de Sciences Po j'y arrive et
je cherchais votre livre auteur de
réformer les retraites qui a été lui
publiée au presse de Sciences Po on le
voit ici s'afficher et Bertrand
Martineau bonsoir bien vous êtes
économiste spécialiste du Marché U du
travail ainsi tu Montaigne et ancien
conseiller social de Nicolas Sarkozy à
l'Elysée Guillaume Daret évidemment est
resté à mes côtés rebonsoir Guillaume
Patrice vous vous avez dit en préparant
l'émission que vous vous êtes vous
pensez que cette réforme des retraites
elle va passer pourquoi aussi sur de
vous non
les paris c'est exactement ça j'ai dit
bon débat si c'est pour dire je sais pas
je peux pas m'avancer bon pour débattre
je pense qu'il faut avoir des positions
celui peut-être que c'est quand même
passé au Sénat ce qui change un peu le
rapport de force néanmoins par rapport à
l'assemblée et que le climat de
l'Assemblée nationale
poussait et dire dans un esprit frondeur
je pense que il est un peu il est un peu
passé je dis pas qu'il reviendra pas
mais ils ont pas beaucoup de temps pour
se réchauffer les uns les autres bon
pour pouvoir aller contre je pense que
il y a un enjeu aussi retaillé au cioti
parce que si scioti tient pas assez de
troupes à l'Assemblée alors que
Retailleau a tenu les siennes au Sénat
chez autiste se met alors qu'il a gagné
quand même la présidence du parti il se
met dans une position de fragilité
parce que il tient pas ses troupes et
Olivier marlex non plus ne tient pas ses
troupes c'est jamais très bon de pas
dire ces troupes quand d'autres membres
du parti Gérard Larcher et Bruno
Retailleau c'était plus facile aux énac
à assembler j'en conviens mais néanmoins
ça ça pose un peu ce rapport de force
puis la troisième personne dont on parle
guerre c'est quand même vous qui est
évoqué lui et il a bien envie d'être le
candidat de LR en 2027 et je pense pas
qu'il est en vie que on soit vraiment
dans cette extrême difficulté parce que
il vote pas bon on passera le 49-3 ça
sera du ressentiment mais ça sera
surtout du ressentiment à gauche et sera
pas du ressentiment à droite donc les
difficultés elles seront là donc moi je
fais le pari que il réussiront peut-être
de justesse peut-être alors si on est à
une voie près il était évident que comme
vous savez ça vient d'être dit Isabelle
prendra pas le risque mais si on est à 5
6 voies disons même aller jusqu'à 10 on
prendra le pari voilà pourquoi je vous
ai dit ça Bertrand Martineau ça va se
jouer dans les derniers heures il y aura
un suspense jusqu'au bout première
partie de la question et deuxième partie
de la question est-ce que Elisabeth Bor
qui joue son avenir politique je dis
j'en sais rien je suis pas commentateur
politique je pense juste que de toute
façon il y aura un dénouement soit par
un vote soit par un 49-3 et dans les
deux dans les deux cas ça ne changera
rien la loi sera votée et en République
en général les lois votées sont
appliquées le seul exemple que je
connais c'est le cas du CPE en 2007 qui
a été en 2006 qui a été promulgué et
contrairement à la lettre de la
Constitution qui est un français en
français l'indicatif en droit est
impératif le président de la République
n'a pas promulgué la loi voilà c'est un
cas unique je crois dans l'histoire de
la cinquième d'ailleurs les syndicats on
appelle Alexandre du CPE on le voit ces
derniers jours voilà mais enfin on est
on est dans une république avec un
pouvoir législatif qui vote les lois et
le prénom de la République est lié en
fait par le vote de l'assemblée et même
s'il y a pas eu vote et qui a eu le 49-3
de toute façon c'est exactement comme si
la loi avait été votée de manière tout à
fait régulière et constitutionnel par le
par le Parlement donc
la question de savoir si le premier vous
savez dans l'histoire de la cinquième le
nombre de fois qu'on a passé des lois
même importante ou 49.3 et bien il y en
a des dizaines et des dizaines et ça n'a
jamais fait sauter un gouvernement ce
qui peut faire sauter un gouvernement
c'est la Constitution c'est que le
gouvernement soit renversé par une
motion par exemple et là bon courage je
suis pas sûr qu'il y a une majorité de
députés qui a envie qui prennent
individuel de voilà ça c'est encore
autre chose voilà
Bruno pallier le l'usage du 49-3 ça
aurait quelles conséquence dans la
stratégie la réaction de l'intersyndical
mais voilà c'est que on peut regarder le
49.3 à l'aune de la Cinquième République
des textes de la tradition politique
effectivement qu'elle requin a fait
passer des textes très importants
structurant aux 49-3 mais on peut aussi
l'analyser à l'eau du contexte politique
actuel et comme vous dites d'une inter
syndicale qui fait monter les enchères
sur la signification du 49-3 qui quelque
part du fait du contexte du fait de la
mobilisation du fait de l'opinion
publique de prendre pas le même sens
que d'autres 49-3 je reprends un regard
sur la CSG sur le RMI c'était vraiment
une façon de gérer à une situation
similaire une majorité récraque relative
mais on n'avait pas une opposition aussi
construite par l'intersydicale une
signification aussi forte qui a été
faite et de toute façon moi je peux vous
mettre que vous ayez raison ou pas ce
qui est important aussi me semble-t-il
c'est de penser aux conséquences
politiques des trois scénarios parce que
je pense qu'on en a discute deux il y en
a trois scénario pour cette semaine il y
en a un c'est voté sur un vote normal
avec le pari c'est là le scénario
roulette russe c'est comme ça que il
s'appelle le deuxième c'est comment ça
s'appelle une grosse Bertha c'est ça
c'est le retrait du projet en réalisant
que c'est beaucoup trop risqué
politiquement dans les semaines et dans
les mois qui viennent et je pense que
c'est important et intéressant de mettre
sur la table ce scénario là d'abord sur
sur un port réaliste
si on se place du côté de l'exécutif
voilà et justement c'est de ça dont
j'avais envie de parler là c'est est-ce
qu'Emmanuel Macron a déjà retiré des
textes bah oui sur la taxe carbone sur
la CSG pour les personnes
âgées il n'a pas impliqué ce qu'il avait
promis sur le glyphosate sur le nez au
quotidien en fait il y en a une dizaine
comme ça est-ce qu'il est mort
politiquement à ma connaissance non il a
été élu il a relancé par un grand débat
pourrait y avoir un grand débat sur le
travail donc ce scénario là il est
parfaitement pensable s'il est calculé à
l'aune du prix politique du fait que la
loi passe et ce prix politique là j'en
ai déjà dit un mot sur ce plateau là il
faut le mesurer pas seulement dans cette
semaine mais dans des semaines dans les
mois et dans les années qui viennent
c'est-à-dire les prochaines échéances
électorales et notamment le poids du
rassemblement national voilà moi c'est
vraiment ce sur quoi je tiens assister
pour le mettre dans le débat nous avons
dans cette réforme
vraiment une accumulation d'ingrédients
dont la science politique a montré qu'il
nourrissent la montée des partis
populistes droites radicales alors ça je
vous redonnerai la parole là-dessus
parce que moi j'ai prévu qu'on y
consacre à un chapitre dans ce débat
mais sur l'hypothèse d'un retrait du
texte tiens ça m'intéresse de de vous
entendre Béatrice honnêtement j'en doute
fort j'en doute fort parce que les
exemples que vous avez cité de retrait
n'était pas j'allais dire aussi
emblématique
pour Emmanuel Macron donc qui a fait de
cette réforme des retraites un des seuls
points un peu nets et clair dans sa
campagne électorale ce qui n'est pas le
cas des autres cas donc que vous avez
cité supprimer 120 000 postes de
fonctionnaires promesses de 2017
abandonné abandonner
d'ailleurs mais complètement
la seule mesure que que les Français ont
peut-être retenu
seconde campagne présidentielle c'était
les retraites
énormément
et la suite sera vraiment pas facile de
mon point de vue à gérer on s'est quand
même avancé y compris en choisissant un
débat contraint dans le temps au
Parlement en 50 jours on a utilisé tout
ce qu'on pouvait pour faire un vote
bloqué au Sénat pour pas perdre de temps
enfin vraiment
on a mouillé la chemise et on a pris des
risques alors moi je serai quand même
extrêmement étonné alors qu'on est à
trois jours de la fin qui puisse dire
bon bah d'accord ok je mets les pouces
d'accord je vous ai pas reçu vous
l'intersyndicale mais on arrête tout et
c'est trop important par un zéro franche
crédibilité c'est crédibilité aux yeux
de qui aux yeux d'une 70% des Français
aux yeux de 90% des actifs c'est à dire
quel crédibilité vous voulez acheter en
tout cas sa politiquement merciment il y
a pas de clients
des Français qui se disent toujours
favorables la réforme mais excusez-moi
vous savez qui sont passés vous le savez
très bien qui sont les retraités les
cannes les professions supérieures c'est
des gens qui ont toujours voté pour
Emmanuel Macron et qui donc n'ont pas
besoin de renforcer la crédibilité le
savent déjà donc oui crédibilité
vis-à-vis des marchés ensuite vers
l'économie sur ton article
de la crédibilité mais
la question est relativement simple
dans cette affaire de réforme des
retraites il y a quand même aucune
surprise ça fait depuis des années qu'on
sait que cette réforme qui s'annonce
sera très impopulaire les sondages qui
sont aujourd'hui sont exactement les
mêmes qu'il y a un an et les mêmes qui a
deux ans donc je fais l'hypothèse
raisonnable que le Président de la
République et le gouvernement n'ont pas
découvert à l'occasion de la réforme que
cette réforme était très impopulaire et
s'ils avaient voulu ne pas la faire il
ne l'aurait pas fait plutôt que de la
faire jusqu'au bout jusqu'à trois jours
avant la le vote d'une loi et ensuite et
de le retirer à ce moment-là enfin ça me
paraîtrait quand même assez bizarre sauf
évidemment un incident gravissime une
affaire malique aussi qui un drame
évidemment mais ça là on est là on est
plus dans la on n'est plus dans la
projection là on est dans l'incident le
drame absolument mais sinon qui avait
été tué par une brigade de voltigeur
lors du manifestation contre la loi 86
il y a eu les jeunes dans la rue et là
les jeunes pourtant c'est pas faute que
certains essayaient de les de les
manipuler les lycéens ou les collégiens
ou les mêmes les écoles les élèves
d'écoles primaire ne sont pas descendues
dans la rue exagéré ah pas tellement
longtemps certains auraient bien été
jusqu'à l'école primaire mais bon peu
importe bon ça n'a pas fonctionné bon
c'est comme ça voilà à partir du moment
où les jeunes sont pas dans la rue voilà
oui la réforme est très très impopulaire
on le savait c'est parfaitement assumé
et sur le le l'absence de réponse
d'Emmanuel Macron à la demande de
rendez-vous de de l'Inter syndicale qui
disent bon on est
on nous a pas laissé négocier on nous a
pas consulté etc entre deux mauvaises
solutions c'est les recevoir et ne rien
dire parce que la concertation a déjà eu
lieu elle a échoué la négociation bah
c'est trop tard toute façon donc c'était
à la sortie il aurait eu droit à il nous
a méprisé et puis la deuxième mauvaise
solution c'est de je ne reçois pas et
ben il nous méprise donc de toute façon
il y avait pas de bonne solution mais
les recevoir parmi ces deux mauvaises
solutions je pense que les recevoir et
n'ont rien à voir à leur dire
c'était peut-être encore parmi les deux
pires c'était peut-être la pire de la
pire que certains c'est dans le fait
d'un gouvernement qui est peu de
probabilité de retirer cette réforme à
trois jours du vote c'est que tous les
ministres vous disent que bien sûr ils
savent depuis longtemps l'impopularité
de cette réforme mais que le quasiment
le seul indicateur qui regarde dans les
études d'opinion c'est ce que les
Français ont la certitude que cette
réforme va se faire il y a que les
Français sont majoritairement opposées
fatalisme mais il sentait ils disent
majoritairement qu'il pense que cette
réforme va se faire et c'est cet
indicateur qu'ils ont surveillé parce
qu'ils disent qu'effectivement dès
qu'une brèche est dans un possible
retrait de la réforme et bien et qu'on
voit que les Français ont le sentiment
que peut-être la réforme ne va pas se
faire c'est là qu'il peut y avoir un
embrasement social
et je pense que la seule possibilité
pour le président de la République
c'était mon te montrer ça détermination
alors il est en plus il aime ce genre de
risques qu'il aime ce genre de solution
c'est ça lui fait pas peur d'une
certaine façon donc il va au feu et et
il va oser aller jusque là et je pense
que cette détermination
contribue à désamorcer une forme de
mobilisation le moindre
possibilité de faiblesse le moindre coin
qu'on puisse
enfoncer dans
solidité on ira au bout
redonne du carburant à la mobilisation
de façon massive donc on joue d'une
certaine façon un peu son on va tout on
est au poker mais
moi je continue à penser que ça peut
passer alors on va on va parler avec
vous Guillaume de des stratégies à la
fois l'intersynica des gouvernement là
dans les dans les jours qui viennent
évidemment il y a cette question de
d'obtenir une majorité à l'assemblée du
nombre de députés LR qui pourrait voter
ou pas la réforme la première ministre
et la convoqué plusieurs de ces
ministres hier après-midi à Matignon
voilà ce qu'on dit Bruno Le Maire c'est
ce matin sur France Info sur la
stratégie adoptée il faut que nous
mettions toutes nos forces dans la
bataille pour la majorité cette semaine
pour dégager une majorité à l'Assemblée
nationale il faut d'abord que la
majorité fasse bloc et quand je vois les
déclarations de François Bayrou le
patron du MoDem de Stéphane séjourné le
patron de renaissance je n'ai aucun
doute que la majorité fera bloc qu'il
s'agisse d'horizon de renaissance ou du
modèle
alors Guillaume on parle de des deux
stratégies
les syndicats effectivement
reconnaissent quand même depuis
plusieurs jours quand vous échangez avec
eux qui sont dans une position délicate
en tout cas dans une situation difficile
l'un des principaux l'un des leaders
syndicaux me dis ce weekend on est dans
une phase très compliquée il faut
l'admettre d'autant plus
qu'effectivement un peu comme un sport
ils ont un peu l'impression de boxer
dans le vide avec effectivement cette
demande d'être reçue par Emmanuel Macron
qui n'a pas été satisfaite ils ont du
mal à trouver le finalement la juste
stratégie et il m'expliquait
qu'effectivement leur stratégie par
cette demande c'était d'essayer de faire
descendre Emmanuel Macron dans l'arène
et que donc il déplore un peu de ne pas
y être parvenu cette méthode Coué
d'autant plus que le gouvernement lui de
son côté a pas l'intention de changer de
stratégie c'est à dire de continuer à
banaliser en quelque sorte la
mobilisation sociale pour essayer
d'emporter la bataille parlementaire
même si effectivement c'est ce qu'on dit
cette bataille parlementaire reste
encore très incertaine et alors on va
détailler les deux possibilités qui sont
presque aussi risquées l'une que l'autre
pour les évadboard alors c'est ce qu'on
disait un instant sur la réception par
le chef de l'état des syndicats là c'est
un peu pareil il y a pas vraiment de
bonne ou de mauvaise solution il y a des
risques dans les deux c'est vrai
qu'Elisabeth borne y compris lors de
cette réunion hier à Matignon ou à la
réuni pour légèrement de son
gouvernement la redit en privé et même
après en public c'est que elle ne
souhaite pas effectivement employer le
49-3 alors méthode Coué oui mais aussi
parce qu'il y a des conséquences
politiques qui seraient importantes pour
elle évidemment ça serait d'abord son
échec à elle parce qu'elle aurait été on
dira qu'elle a été incapable de
construire une majorité sur ce texte
parce que quand même ça compliquera un
peu politiquement la suite du
quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron même si le
49-3 c'est parfaitement légal c'est
parfaitement constitutionnel
effectivement il y a toujours cette
image de brutalité et puis parce que
c'est ce que vous disiez Louis Armand
craint un peu quand même que ça redonne
un peu de carburant au syndicat qui sont
dans une passe difficile donc ça c'est
l'objectif d'Elizabeth baume mais il y a
autre chose qui va probablement
peut-être s'imposer à elle c'est ce
qu'on appelle le principe de réalité
parce que
les calculettes sont de sortie les
téléphones portables chauffent c'est ce
que me disait un leader de la majorité
depuis hier et pour l'instant quand ils
font les comptes et bien tout simplement
ils arrivent pas à savoir s'ils ont une
majorité donc est-ce qu'à 5 voix près à
10 fois prêt Elisabeth borne prendra ou
non le risque d'un vote classique Thomas
il y a quelque chose qu'il faut jamais
oublier c'est que la personne qui se
trouve au Palais de l'Élysée Emmanuel
Macron ce qui lui importe c'est une
seule chose c'est que cette réforme soit
votée aujourd'hui et quel que soit la
méthode donc vous me croyez pas du tout
un retrait pour reprendre ce que disait
tout à l'heure vous vous n'y croyez pas
Bruno pallier vous l'avez un peu évoqué
tout à l'heure mais vous dites qu'une
une réforme des retraites coécrites
entre le gouvernement et les LR
imaginons qu'elle soit votée imaginons
qu'elle soit votée avec des députés LR
suffisamment nombreux vous dites ce
serait quand même une victoire en trompe
l'oeil pourquoi on utilise une métaphore
du feu donc
Emmanuel Macron joue avec le feu et
disons ça passe les gens sont résignés
qu'est-ce qui se passe il y a des
braises qui couvent et elle attend
qu'une chose c'est de se réactiver donc
on on va quitter la métaphore on va
faire de l'analyse qu'est-ce qui
alimente le ressentiment social le
ressentiment politique qui débouche sur
la montée des parties populistes extrême
droite dans tous les pays d'Europe alors
le premier point à rappeler c'est que la
France est pas émue vous savez qui était
au second tour des deux dernières
élections présidentielles vous savez
qu'il y a 89 députés donc on raisonne
non pas sur de la scénario
science-fiction pour dans 25 ans on
parle de 2027 d'accord qu'est-ce qui
qu'est-ce qui se passe il y a une un des
ressorts majeurs du vote pour ce type de
partie il est de dire il ne nous écoute
pas je veux pas forcément en passer par
là mais il n'y a pas d'autres voix
possible il n'y a pas de d'autres moyens
de se faire entendre que de voter pour
ces gens là puisque les autres on
n'arrivent pas à se faire entendre donc
on est typiquement dans ce type de
scénario quoi que vous disiez des
sondages à 70%, 90% plusieurs millions
etc je passe ok donc le message c'est
que j'ai pas d'autres alternatives que
cela pour le faire deuxième chose
qu'est-ce qui alimente
volonté du rejet des élites il nous
manque c'est un ressort vraiment très
habituel que l'on trouve dans beaucoup
d'analyses voilà qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé sur les 1200 euros et sur un
certain nombre d'autres choses pas moi
qui vais le qualifier de mensonge mais
beaucoup de gens le comprennent comme ça
et plus fondamentalement si on regarde
le contenu de la réforme des retraites
qu'est-ce que vous avez vous avez une
réforme qui est parfaitement comprise et
qui va s'appliquer si elle s'applique à
partir de septembre donc c'est pas un
machin de vous voyez en 1993 ça se
terminait en 2005 c'est septembre les
gens ils repoussent de trois mois
premier janvier 2024 en 2024 ils doivent
travailler six mois trois mois six mois
de plus donc c'est très concret et il y
a des moi j'ai fait le calcul plus 3
millions de personnes qui vont être
concernées d'ici 2027 donc ça fait ça
fait un petit peu de monde je rappelle
il y a 5 millions d'écarts de voix entre
Emmanuel Macron et Marine Le Pen donc
c'est quelque chose de très contraint
qui change la vie des gens sont pas
d'accord pour ce faire pour que ça que
ça s'applique qui plus particulièrement
va être touchée donc pas les cadres pas
les électeurs les 30% parlait tout à
l'heure les plus modestes ont reçu
quelque chose même s'ils sont pas gâtés
par le système de retraite la moitié des
personnes les plus modestes doivent
attendre 67 ans c'est il est classe
moyenne en déclin pour le dire comme ça
qui sont celles qui vont être les plus
impactés c'est déjà un peu l'électorat
naturel
c'est le nouveau c'est ça la grande
nouveauté il y a 10-15 ans dans tous les
partis européens mais c'est là où il y a
un réservoir voilà moi ce que ce que je
veux dire c'est que l'analyse nous
montre qu'il y a de la braise et que il
faut peut-être mettre ça dans le
départs continuent de l'analyser dans ce
débat et d'ailleurs je vous propose
d'écouter la réaction du président du
Rassemblement national c'est d'être hier
sur France Inter à propos du 49-3 et de
et de ce qui va se passer à l'Assemblée
là dans les dans les jours à venir
je veux dire ce matin ce midi en tout
cas aux Français qui nous écoutent que
en l'état actuel des choses rien n'est
fait et que
même si la commission mixte paritaire
compte en son sein très peu d'opposants
à la réforme des retraites puisque il y
aura je crois que 4 ou 5 personnes qui
seront critiques de ce texte de loi il y
aura un vote très important à
l'Assemblée nationale et 49-3 ou pas je
pense que nous pouvons encore éviter le
pire le pire serait évidemment
l'adoption de ce texte de loi qui va
cibler le travail et qui va notamment
cibler les Français les plus modestes
Bertrand Martineau je voyais prendre des
notes pendant que que Bruno pallier
faisait sa démonstration qu'est-ce que
est-ce que vous êtes aussi est-ce que
vous projetez aussi loin parce qu'on
peut se dire c'est dans quatre ans
il y a pas de sujet moi je suis d'accord
à peu près avec cette analyse
effectivement il y a un sujet classe
moyenne parce qu'effectivement les
cadres sont moins moins touchés et les
plus populaires les classes les plus
populaires sont moins touchés également
voilà en fait c'est effectivement un peu
les deux alors typiquement c'est un peu
les enseignants par exemple voilà eux
ils se prennent effectivement
essentiellement les deux ans je rappelle
quand même en moyenne c'est un chiffre
qui est pourtant officiel et public que
en moyenne par rapport à la réforme
Touraine et à l'horizon 2030 l'impact de
la réforme c'est 9 mois de travail
supplémentaire c'est pas non plus la fin
du monde mais derrière cette cette
effectivement cette d'ailleurs cette
moyenne de 9 mois
non pardon 7 mois très exactement 7 mois
mais derrière cette moyenne
effectivement vous avez des vous avez
des gens qui perdent beaucoup puis des
gens qui perdent peu donc effectivement
un sujet classe moyenne probablement
cela étant on peut quand même se
demander si l'élection 2027 va se jouer
sur un sujet qui serait par exemple les
retraites ou s'il va pas se sujet il va
pas se jouer sur un mécontentement
beaucoup plus large
et qui dépasse très très très largement
le problème du retrait cette question
des retraites c'est un symptôme
fondamentalement vers les gens vont pas
faire une guerre civile pour les
retraites c'est pas vrai le sujet il est
beaucoup plus profond que ça c'est les
questions de pouvoir d'achat c'est
question d'immigration et question de
sécurité le sentiment d'un déclin du
pays le désindustrialisation etc enfin
l'abandon d'un certain nombre de
territoires je donne des banalités
énormes mais et un des aspects de ce
déclin c'est que nous ne sommes plus
capables de nous payer compte tenu des
évolutions de la productivité etc nous
ne sommes plus capables de nous payer
c'est un des symptômes du déclin le
système de protection sociale qui était
le plus généreux de la planète quasiment
voilà et donc et donc cette réforme il
faut la faire mais non éventuellement
continuer de pouvoir se payer ça je ne
sais pas quelle est la réussite je ne
suis pas un homme politique simplement
je pense que la solution évidemment
toute réforme impopulaire enfin c'est
une porte ouverte j'enfonce des portes
ouvertes désolé mais toute réforme
impopulaire renforce les populistes bah
oui une fois qu'on a dit ça bah oui
c'est vrai bon c'est pas donc ça veut
dire qu'il faut pas pour autant
complètement dérivé donc attaquons les
autres problèmes attaquons les problèmes
effectivement de pouvoir d'achat réglons
les problèmes d'immigration et réglons
tous ces problèmes là qui vont être des
sujets 2027 mais on peut pas dire non
plus que tout va se jouer sur les
retraites et que la retraite c'est le
point nodal de tous l'équilibre
politique français il y a bien d'autres
sujets qui vont qui vont jouer
probablement alors il y a un gros sujet
que vous avez pas mentionné c'est le
travail et il se trouve que les
mobilisations c'est sur le travail les
conditions de travail l'intensification
du travail le sentiment de perte de bien
de travail de sens de participation aux
décisions etc donc ça c'est le gros
sujet qui a permis de révéler la
mobilisation les enjeux est-ce que
montre pas mal d'études de sciences
politiques c'est qu'en fait un des
ressorts du vote ouvrier du vote employé
pour ces parties un peu plus de droites
radicales c'est le sentiment d'être
traité comme un comme un simple numéro
dans une entreprise c'est le sentiment
de ne plus participer aux collectif de
travail ça c'est un ressort très fort ça
c'est un premier point le deuxième point
non bien sûr une élection je fais pas
sur un seul enjeu par contre qu'est-ce
qui alimente le feu enfin c'est
puisqu'on a cette métaphore et moi je je
pense qu'on peut montrer j'ai essayé de
le montrer dans mon bouquin dans
différents écrits que les réformes des
retraites en particulier quand elles
font l'objet de débats et de
mobilisation sont extrêmement saillantes
c'est la notion de science politique et
donc ça compte on s'en rappelle alors je
peux vous citer je suis à 95 97 je peux
en citer d'autres mais j'aimerais bien
citer une c'est l'Italie réforme Fornero
de 2011 imposée clairement l'un pour le
coup par Bruxelles ça c'est dit par le
gouvernement 2018
la 5 étoiles et la Liga mettre dans leur
programme et mettre beaucoup en avant le
fait qu'ils vont revenir en arrière sur
cette réforme bien sûr s'ils ont fait la
règle descend mais bien sûr ils ont fait
la règle des centres qui fait que les
beaucoup de gens ont pu partir plus tôt
que les 66 ans et demi annoncés pour
laquelle je crois Meloni est en partie
revenu sur certains aspects elle essaye
de monter à 101
le risque du populisme il est là il est
tout à fait sérieux et c'est pas parce
qu'on dit qu'ils vont aller jusqu'au
bout que on n'est pas conscient on
risque peut-être d'une victoire de
Marine Le Pen d'autant plus que le
rassemblement national joue avec un
certain savoir-faire dans les débats on
sait pas très bien ce qu'il ferait à la
place ils disent pas ils disent pas
grand chose mais en tout cas c'est pas
eux qui ont je vais prendre une évasion
mille bazars à l'Assemblée nationale et
que Bardella c'est s'exprimer avec un
peu de retenue il en rajoute pas trop
Marine Le Pen sur France Inter
idem très très bien donc tout ça leur
donne une donne une image de crédibilité
pour pouvoir gouverner donc déjà on est
dans une situation là je suis tout à
fait d'accord avec vous où il y a un
risque majeur
je vais vous laisser la parole est-ce
que pour autant il faudrait ne pas faire
une telle réforme à
je reviens sur le fait en disant on est
tellement engagé il fallait peut-être
pas la faire mais ça y est on est on est
parti on l'a fait pour des marchés
financiers il fallait impérativement
montrer que on prenait les choses en
main les taux d'intérêt quand on
emprunte commence à monter il fallait
essayer de calmer le jeu moi je reste
convaincu que c'est un des moteurs
importants pour lesquels on a fait cette
cette réforme mais je voudrais dire
aussi que bon on peut toujours tirer des
plans sur la comète que la seule qui
sera encore candidate c'est Marine Le
Pen c'est à dire que Macron ne sera plus
candidat ça sera nécessairement
quelqu'un d'autre s'il était encore
candidat on pourrait continuer à
focaliser sur lui l'opposition c'est
encore lui lui il va être retiré du jeu
celle qui va rester c'est effectivement
Marine Le Pen et
IDE du côté de l'intersyndicale vous
perdez vos deux grands leaders syndicaux
au printemps tant Laurent Berger que
Philippe Martinez et là on va avoir des
figures nouvelles et je pense que ça
peut aussi la rancœur sera là le
ressentiment sera là la colère sera
toujours là mais on n'aura pas les mêmes
interlocuteurs et sur la discussion du
travail c'est le dernier point que je
voudrais soulever pourquoi ne partons
jamais de l'attitude du patronat dans la
façon dont il gère ses salariés ses
employés on réclame de l'état de régler
ce problème mais bon son de soi on peut
peut-être aussi s'interroger sur comment
les patrons gèrent leur propre personnel
est-ce que si ce sentiment de j'allais
dire de mépris de non-sens au travail
mais c'est aussi au patronat qu'il faut
poser la question vous remarquerez qu'il
est très discret quasiment pas entendu
allez je il y a encore beaucoup de
thèmes à aborder donc je vous propose de
parler maintenant de la commission mix
parité parce qu'on essaye de se projeter
dans les enjeux de cette semaine je
propose à Steve Jourdain de nous
rejoindre tout de suite rebonsoir Steve
donc là CMP la commission mixte
paritaire qu'est-ce que c'est une sorte
de partie de pêche pour Isabelle borne
la première ministre actuellement et
bien d'appâté d'attirer de convaincre
les élus qui participent à cette
commission oui oui parce que les
contours définitifs de cette réforme
doivent être précisément déterminer dans
cette CMP très concrètement la CMP et
bien c'est une commission qui est
composée de 7 sénateurs et de 7 députés
on va voir la liste des noms s'afficher
côté Sénat et bien on trouve Catherine
de roche présidente de la commission des
affaires sociales René Paul Savary
rapporterait l'air de la réforme
Philippe mouiller président à l'ère de
la commission des affaires sociales et
Isabelle doit nous rapporteur général de
la commission des affaires sociales
c'est une centriste les socialistes
Monique Lubin et Corinne Ferret ou
encore clavier yakovelli pour la
majorité
présidentielle en font également partie
ils ont rendez-vous mercredi à huis clos
dans une salle de l'Assemblée nationale
que va-t-il se passer dans cette salle
on aimerait bien savoir on aimerait bien
savoir tout ce beau monde va tenter de
se mettre d'accord sur un texte commun
c'est-à-dire que théoriquement chaque
partie chaque groupe doit faire des
compromis on peut imaginer qu'il en
sortira quelque chose puisque les LR et
Renaissance sont majoritaires dans cette
réunion ils sont tous favorables à la
retraite à 64 ans mais attention
attention il y a des lignes rouges de
part et d'autre écoutez Bruno Retailleau
s'était hier je suis conscient
simplement je dis à la majorité
présidentielle comme au gouvernement que
le Sénat ne laissera pas piétiner ses
acquis alors dans le détail quelles sont
ces lignes rouges elles sont nombre de
trois on l'a dit les sénateurs sont
favorables à la retraite à 64 ans mais
il souhaite imposer quelques apports et
quelques modifications au gouvernement
ils veulent mettre en avant notamment la
question des maires de famille le Sénat
on le rappelle a voté pour une surcote
de leur pension de retraite exigeant
ceci en matière de travail des seniors
les sénateurs se sont prononcés en
faveur de la création d'un CDI pour les
plus âgés qui seraient au chômage enfin
sujet qui revient souvent ici à la
Chambre haute les élus souhaitent
muscler le dispositif contre la fraude
aux allocations sociales autant de
mesures de questions qui feront débat
Thomas mercredi lors de la CMP et après
après mercredi et c'est la grande
question si la CMP est conclusive
c'est-à-dire qu'un terrain d'entente est
trouvé entre député et sénateurs
l'accord sera examiné jeudi matin 9h au
Sénat pour un vote finale sur le texte
le texte passera ensuite à l'Assemblée
nationale à 15h c'est là que
politiquement le gouvernement va jouer
très gros puisque si aucune majorité de
députés ne se dessine Elisabeth
Elisabeth borne pourrait avoir recours à
l'article 49-3 dont vous avez déjà parlé
tout à l'heure Thomas merci beaucoup
Steve Jourdain pour toute ces
explications
votre expérience de de cabinet président
essentiel à une CMP alors c'est beaucoup
plus facile quand on tient sa majorité
il peut y avoir des surprises là en
commission mixte c'est plus facile
surtout quand elles ont menace
c'est très bien parce que cette réforme
est fait faire du droit constitutionnel
faire plein de choses elle va peut-être
même finalement obligé les partenaires
sociaux à réfléchir à la question de
l'emploi des seniors aussi donc elle a
des effets positifs finalement parce que
les questions de l'emploi designers
c'est un sujet qui doit se traiter non
pas au niveau
national et interprofessionnel mais au
niveau des branches professionnelles et
des entreprises parmi qui parle alors
oui c'était pas au gouvernement de
mettre ça sur la table avant de faire
voter une réforme sur sur
le dialogue social s'en empare et le
dialogue social en France est un des
problèmes que nous avons et on peut
toujours sauter comme un cabri en disant
le travail le travail le travail oui
effectivement je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec vous derrière la question
des retraites entre autre chose il y a
la question du travail bon mais la
question du travail ça se règle pas par
la loi c'est à dire autant la retraite
c'est une question de loi c'est un sujet
macro-financier et qui c'est un cadre
ensuite effectivement le travail des
seniors et le travail de manière
générale c'est des questions qui doivent
se traiter par le dialogue social au
niveau des branches et les entreprises
et alors j'insiste sur la question des
branches parce qu'il y a des questions
de métier et les métiers c'est souvent
des branches c'est au niveau de la
branche de transport routier vous avez
de la pénibilité en transport routier
vous avez des pénibilités comme
aide-soignant c'est dans les branches
les branches de la du secteur de la
santé etc donc il y a des choses à faire
et c'est là que il faudrait que les
partenaires sociaux
récupèrent finalement le bébé et négocie
dans ses branches quitte à créer
effectivement des dispositifs de
branches pour de la transition emploi
retraite le passage à temps partiel des
aménagements de poste des choses comme
ça
si vous êtes d'accord avec cette année
est-ce que finalement les partenaires
sociaux ne se sont pas suffisamment
saisis de cette question alors
clairement on discute de l'emploi des
seniors en France depuis la réforme
Balladur de 1993 et la façon dont on en
discute ça c'est pas que les partenaires
sociaux c'est les experts c'est les
gouvernements a eu à une façon
particulière d'en discuter c'est à dire
on discute par la négatif c'est-à-dire
qui
est à des emplois pénibles et comment on
fait pour les faire partir on ne se pose
pas la question de comment on fait pour
rendre les emplois moins pénibles et là
vous dites ça relève de des branches moi
les comparaisons internationales me
disent que on peut aussi avoir des
incitations nationales des grands plans
nationaux donc vous connaissez l'exemple
de la Finlande où il y a
un objectif qui est assigné pour tout le
monde qui est porté par le gouvernement
mobiliser les seniors comme un trésor
national c'était l'expression
mettre les moyens aussi de subventions
de soutien aux formations pour les
seniors soutien à l'amélioration des
conditions de travail c'est de donner
des signaux donner des moyens ce qu'on
n'a pas fait au gouvernement on peut
être étonné que vous dites ça mais la
France est quand même un pays où l'État
joue un rôle assez important donc il
pourrait donner les choses et du coup ça
m'amène à un point que je voulais dire
vous dites là vous dites bon ben oui
c'est comme ça voilà
[Musique]
un tripartisme qui n'arrive pas à
vouloir partager des décisions donc
l'honneur des décisions réussir parce
qu'on est encore sur ce genre de choses
alors que la question c'est quand même
comme vous dites la prospérité c'est
quand même le bénin-être au travail
c'est quand même avancer ensemble
un dernier thème abordé moi je pense que
la faiblesse du syndicatisme en France
est aussi un des facteurs explicatifs de
cette difficulté autre partie
c'est-à-dire c'est un rapport de force
aussi pour négocier le syndicalisme
mensuel Le syndicatisme au Danemark le
syndicaliste en Finlande c'est tout à
fait autre chose à des quoi on est un
petit peu en dessous de 10% de gens
syndiqués en France ça vous crée pas un
rapport de force pour se faire pour se
faire clairement entendre dans un pays
où la tradition du consensus
effectivement assez peu partagé alors
justement on va parler pour terminer de
la stratégie de l'Inter syndicale et je
vous propose d'écouter tout de suite la
réaction de Laurent Berger secrétaire
général de la CFDT c'était samedi dans
la manifestation sur la suite du
mouvement voilà ce qu'il dit tu es très
clair la CFDT elle respectera toujours
la légalité c'est dans nos gènes la
légalité c'est le vote au Parlement
c'est le y compris de 49-3 qui serait
une forme de vice démocratique ça serait
réforme mais on pourra pas dire que
c'est illégal mais le problème c'est pas
la légalité seulement donc il sera
question c'est la cohésion sociale de
notre pays dont il va être question dans
les semaines à venir et donc là on en
discutera mercredi soir en inter
syndicale et et j'implore une certaine
manière je demande à ceux qui dirigent
ce pays de sortir de cette forme de déni
du mouvement social et je vous conseille
de dire un article intéressant dans les
échos ce matin signer Cécile Cornudet
qui qui nous dresse le portrait d'un
Laurent Berger un peu bloqué entre l'ADN
de la CFDT réformiste ouverte en
négociation et la tentation d'une
radicalisation temple esthermeula face
au silence de l'exécutif Bertrand
Martineau comment vous l'analysez ça si
on se projette sur que vous nous disiez
c'est à dire il faut qu'on lance des
négociations sur le sens du travail sur
l'emploi des seniors en France etc
comment faire si un syndicat comme la
CFDT veut plus forcément venir à la
table après après la séquence qu'on est
en train de vivre alors d'abord je pense
que Laurent Berger est dans son rôle et
il peut difficilement tenir un autre
discours les syndicats parmi les
critères de la représentativité salariés
il y a le respect des valeurs
républicaines bon euh faire bloquer le
pays pour
pour ne pas appliquer une loi qui a été
votée c'est une grève insurrectionnelle
on est dans d'autres choses et c'est pas
effectivement la culture de la CFDT et
je pense que au niveau des dirigeants
d'ailleurs les autres les autres les
autres syndicats suivront le même le
même chemin donc c'est pas étonnant de
la part de Laurent Berger c'est tout à
fait normal bon donc à partir de là ça
ne veut pas dire c'est pas parce qu'il y
a eu cette affaire des retraites que les
syndicats et en particulier la CFDT vont
poser le stylo ils vont plus vouloir
négocier sur quoi que ce soit parce
qu'il y a plein de choses à venir dans
l'agenda alors on parlait des sujets
effectivement de je reviens sur les
sujets de branche professionnelle je ne
dis pas du tout que les partenaires
sociaux sont responsables de la
situation et je dis juste que c'est vrai
que jusqu'à présent les négociations sur
l'emploi des seniors sur les
aménagements de fin de carrière etc on
peut pas dire que ça a été au centre de
l'agenda social quand même parce qu'il y
avait un consensus finalement pour
éliminer enfin pour se débarrasser des
seigneurs le plus vite possible
j'entends ce que vous dites sur le le la
volonté on va dire des syndicats
participés mais Guillaume d'arrêt ils
sont quand même ils sortent de cette de
cette référence c'est pas tout à fait
terminé on ne sait pas ce qui va se
passer mais ils peuvent sortir de cette
séquence retraite quand même avec un
lien on l'évoquait tout à l'heure qui
est quasi rompu avec avec l'exécutif et
donc ce que ce que vous vous avez
entendu dans des discussions avec des
leaders syndicaux c'est peut-être qu'il
va ils vont avoir du mal il faut pas
compter sur nous quoi il faut pas
compter sur nous il faudra pas venir
nous chercher alors ça sera peut-être
dans un premier temps effectivement
peut-être que dans un second temps il
reviendront mais c'est une préoccupation
qu'on entend pas une inquiétude pas que
du côté des violences syndicaux
d'inquiétude qu'on entend y compris chez
certains ministres
bien conscient effectivement
de la colère qu'il y a sur la question
du pouvoir d'achat ou sur d'autres
domaines et qui est quel est le discours
qu'on va pouvoir tenir quel est le
discours que le gouvernement va pouvoir
tenir après cette réforme des retraites
si elle est adoptée pour montrer qu'il
entend cette colère en matière notamment
de lutte contre l'inflation en matière
de pouvoir d'achat et comment on
réessaye de mettre les syndicats autour
de la table mais il y a un ministre qui
me disait moi je n'exclut pas que
pendant trois ans on n'est plus la CFDT
autour de la table alors c'est peut-être
une façon de de taper un peu fort pour
provoquer un électrochoc mais il y en a
quand même un certain nombre qui sont
inquiets de la méthode dont ça c'est
fait Béatrice Gibelins sur la suite du
mouvement là cette semaine peut-être que
la loi sera adoptée on verra bien sous
sous quelle forme quelle peut être la
suite du mouvement pour est-ce qu'il y a
un risque par exemple que le mouvement
échappe au syndicat je n'y crois pas
vraiment je n'y crois pas vraiment
je reviens sur toujours ce même sondage
c'est à dire que 70 des Français pensent
que cette loi sera votée va ou 49,3 et
de toute façon quelle sera appliquée
donc dans leur tête voilà c'est on
n'aura pas gagné je pense que pour les
syndicats et pour les leaders syndicaux
qui ont fait deux 62 ans la ligne rouge
à partir de laquelle ils n'ont plus
voulu bouger les mettent eux aussi dans
une situation qui peut être perçue comme
une situation d'échec alors ça peut
avoir des effets extrêmement négatifs on
nous écoute pas c'est n'importe quoi
alors il y a que la violence pour se
faire entendre comme les gilets jaunes
l'ont fait eux ils ont eu 12 milliards
totalement le discours de la Robert j'ai
dit on réunit un million de personnes
dans la rue quasiment sans aucun
problème quelques débardeurs nous
n'obtenons rien là où les autres ont
obtenu très en dernier mot l'émission se
termine donc revenons là dessus ça moi
je pense très très sincèrement que il va
y avoir comme une sorte de dépression
dans l'opinion publique après ce bombe
on sera là pour l'analyser évidemment
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce
débat la revue aérodote géopolitique des
ressources naturelles la voilà c'est le
numéro de ce premier trimestre et puis
Bruno palier votre livre réformé les
retraites qui est publiées au presse de
Sciences Po merci encore à tous d'avoir
participé à cette émission je vous dis à
demain évidemment et puis notez que
Eric woert Custer de l'assemblée et
ancien ministre du budget sera l'invité
Dorian Mancini demain matin à 8h belle
soirée à toutes et à tous